once we build an agi system say psych is
some part of some part of it
and
say it's very possible that you would be
one of the first people
that can sit down in the room
let's say with her and have a
conversation
what would you ask her what would you
talk about
looking at all of the
content
out there
on the web and so on
what are the
what are the some possible solutions to
big problems that the world has that
people haven't really thought of before
that are not being
properly or at least adequately
pursued
what are some novel solutions that you
can think of that we haven't
that might work and that might be worth
considering
so that is a damn good question given
that the agi is going to be somewhat
different from human intelligence
it's still going to make some mistakes
that we wouldn't make but it's also
possibly going to notice
some blind spots we have
and um i would i would love it
as a test of is it really
on a par with our intelligences
can it help spot some of the blind spots
that we have
so the two-part question of can you help
identify what are the big problems in
the world and two
what are some novel solutions to those
problems that are not being
talked about by anyone
yeah and some of those may become
um you know infeasible or reprehensible
or something but some of them might be
actually great things to look at
you know if you if you go back and look
at some of the most
powerful discoveries that have been made
like relativity and
superconductivity and so on a lot of
them
were
cases where
someone took seriously the idea that
there might actually be
um
a non-obvious answer
to it to a question so in einstein's
case it was um yeah the lorenz
transformation is known um nobody
believes that it's actually the way
reality works what if it were the real
way that reality actually worked
so you know a lot of people don't
realize he didn't actually work out that
equation he just sort of took it
seriously
or in the case of superconductivity you
have this v equals ir equation where r
is resistance and so on and um
it was being mapped at lower and lower
temperatures but everyone thought that
was just bump on a log research
to show that v equals ir always held
and then when some
graduate student
got to a slightly lower temperature and
showed that resistance suddenly dropped
off everyone just assumed that they did
it wrong
and they and it was only a little while
later that they realized it was um it
was actually a new phenomenon or in the
case of um
the
h pylori bacteria causing stomach ulcers
where everyone thought that stress and
stomach acid caused ulcers
and when a doctor
in
australia
claimed it was actually a bacterial
infection
he couldn't get anyone seriously to
listen to him and he had to
ultimately inject himself
with the bacteria to show that he
suddenly developed a life-threatening
ulcer
in order to get other doctors to
seriously consider that so there are all
sorts of things where
humans are locked into paradigms what
thomas kuhn called paradigms and we
can't get out of them very easily so a
lot of ai is locked into the
deep learning machine learning paradigm
right now
and
almost all of us and almost all sciences
are locked into current paradigms and
you know kun's point was
pretty much you have to wait for people
to die
in order for the new generation to
escape those paradigms and i think that
one of the things that would change that
sad reality is if we had
trusted agis that could help take a step
back
and question
some of the paradigms that we're
currently locked into
yeah it would accelerate the paradigm
shifts and yes in human science and
progress
you